Speaker 1: I got a very funny voicemail from
the Egg Man yesterday on the bonus show,
Pat talked about his Thanksgiving break. Very
exciting visit to the country of Colombia.
I talked about a pretty low key Thanksgiving
with half of the people around me panicking
about Omicron and Eggman didn't didn't find
my stories interesting. Take a listen, Pat.
Speaker 5: How was your vacation? I went to
Columbia and did stuff. Dave, how's your vacation?
Omicron Omicron on the coronavirus virus. Omicron
everybody is scared on the card. I have no
idea what you did for the holiday break,
Dave, because all you said was Omicron Omicron,
like 13 times. Um, I don't know. I hope you
did more than just Omaha traveler and brother.
Speaker 1: Barely. I not only shalom, but happy
Hanukkah Eggman. We do tonight is the third is it?
Yeah, third night tonight. Third candle goes on
on tonight. Yeah, no. I mean, I said I didn't do
much and there was just a lot of it was it was.
I was around a lot of Omicron talk. I apologize
that it does not suit the eggman, but that is
what it was. On today's bonus show, we will talk
about Tulsi Gabbard new declaration that America
is not a racist country has proven by the Ahmaud
Arbery verdict. We will talk about the latest CNN
host Chris Cuomo, accused of using his media
sources to find information about his brother,
Andrew Cuomo's accusers. And a Texas
father has shot his own daughter dead.
Accidentally, we might call it negligently
while hunting, while hunting another tragedy
with a gun. All of those stories and more on
today's bonus show. Sign up at Join Patricof.